oddio ciao a tutti oggi andiamo a vedere
dei trucchetti per ragazze per donne per
femmine
infatti quel valore come reagirei tu che
sono un po strani e molto particolari
molto particolari prima di iniziare devo
dire una cosa importantissima alle date
del firma copia unica per i troppi
quindi quella che bene date e orari e
luoghi
segnatevi lì è il mio libro vi lascio il
link in descrizione per ordinarlo solo
motor se volete potete comprare libri
via poerio di tutti non vediamo l'ora di
vedere io comunque si perderebbe sono
pronti per guardarvi che avuto cosa ne
pensino le altre ha visti perché sono
super curioso visto d'amelia del trucco
da allora vediamo un po una felpa per
aggiusterà tempo ancora non è solo con
ragazze romene per chiunque
alle spalle del re il sistema può solo
su di me tra una clip fondi non si
vedono più
questo è utile super seno si sta male
jeans ancora elastico
due calzini se il freddo di veit
esilissimo collant
se metti della lacca per capelli non si
graffiano non si rompono
[Applauso]
[Musica]
è come fare con una squadra così carino
finora non c'è niente di scandaloso ma
tornerà un po scandalo in cui ragioni
vedere quel punto se c'è un altro e
lucas con ricavi il copricapo
bellissimo il cappellino da basket beach
sulla visiera
no perché sembra gli aldo adesso basta
no ben penso batte questo per un
progetto no ma perché ciao parte
greeting c'è allora non lo so di temi
web rimpiazzano questo voglio il buco di
altri animali d'europa foglia ma va bene
lo è ma questo succede sempre un bene
scrive una storia una donna franca a una
tv libera in un centro di singole
industrie sono freddi
mi sono fatto il teletrasporto tutti i
toni ed io per forza stare con lei
firmato né così le cose
wow fedelissimo bella ammesse essere
sempre che i pantaloni mi stanno troppo
lunghi cucirli cosa devo provarlo se
avete provato cui questi trucchetti
iscrizioni commenti quali avete provate
se funzionano un po strano a tipo una
londra viola aveva la cucina tipo come
tastiera avanti
[Applauso]
e così sporca per far capire che non
sono che più la devi tagliare ma che fa
un sacco di diverso tipo mozzano e
simili mi sento
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non so per me un po bruttina oramai
questa estate non mi auguro non è
riciclare le cose vecchie però non
pubblicherà tutto con i jeans insomma
cotone
[Musica]
cosa stiano anticiparvi comporta
bicchiere un portagioie il porta spinto
fin lì bello è bello questo vediamo
scuola altri copricapo una maglietta
fermarsi dissi che se una catenina d'oro
che brava a un topo tip
[Musica]
hp non ha aderito alla vestito finora mi
stanno piacendo praticamente tutti
questi trucchetti che credo possa fare
due passi e poi dopodichè tutti
finora sono contenta voglio trovare il
trucchetto scandaloso quello che ogni
volta ci fanno ridere un sacco bello che
presto in questo non visto di
trasformare le scarpe in una sorta di
stivaletto da una calza un po
particolare non mi piacciono
vediamo una camicia così anche per
l'uomo non è solo per donne
certo sono c'è una doccia vediamo a sta
mettendo l'elastico
e anche questo sarà un sacco una donna
ecco perché l'ha solo con le donne
canino si sveni con le occhiaie pagato
realtà survivor leader ma si sa a cosa
dovrebbe funzionare con ivy the verde
empaticamente sono scomparse
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ai nomi c'è un'area a sé finito olio
d'oliva perdere funziona così sei pronta
per la bruschetta si mette in porta
acqua allora questo momento non si
chiamano italiano pixel e oli essenziali
[Musica]
per la faccia vento nullo spruzzino
mattino perché in pratica questa e
strutto olio di cocco social micron ci
mettiamo al fondo la vita e fai un
rossetto allora finora non c'è niente di
scandaloso dove stoni trucchetti
scandaloso che vediamo noi rivolta ma
perchè vi piaccia veramente una più di
così coi ranghi negli occhi il rossetto
questo sappiamo un problema chi lo sma 6
la maschera pilota cosa che siamo
proprio a dirti la lunga corsa per sé
mettere la loro reale e il corpo e può
tirarlo via e rimane il segno io l'avevo
trovato il trucchetto però non rimaneva
molto il colore del rossetto
se ne va un po a chiazze quindi poi dopo
non da una guardia quando lo so io però
[Musica]
cosa si capisce bene queste cose perché
seguono in pratica succede che con tutti
i trucchi il sopracciglio anche
un'attrice più grossa e quindi a
prestare facendo valere il cuore questi
li ho provati non quelli fatti da me ma
ha comprati ma non esce bene chi non è
semplicemente bene contro va per fare la
stessa inclinazione per fare lo stencil
noti su qualsiasi sera inclinazioni
questo oggetto mito si lavora in queste
spiega figlia della metropolitana e dice
di aiutare anche la siria ma come clima
car così non ti sporchi la falda un ramo
che per le corride perché porta questa
lavagna a un suo libro storia nata
perché dopo vedendo quello che ragazza
questa cosa io sono ciglia finte però
non rimangono neanche dopo un po il
bianco scompare a permettere quindi la
cosa pressante
hai visto di differenza zuccherate solo
[Musica]
sentitissima base li na li plus per fare
un balsamo labbra bravo dove questi
trucchetti colombo forza davvero di
prigione brutti ricordi che basta mall
aprano bocca con la bello ma sotto ci
mettiamo nello store basso a destra
lo trovo anch'io piccolo ai lavoretti
un'aula facciamo male
oddio come la scusa come ho fatto
erano anzi a una zucca in zucca sta
chiamando vecchia storia palazzi per
azione
me lo sento un ambiente cinque minuti
sono pronta
[Musica]
un metodo per fare i poco il comune
approvato se un prete di provarlo e così
sembra che a giusta perfetto poi si
mostra anno non e infatti ho capito ma
metto solo di ventura così di nuovo
software la fronte
dai che cade non puoi capire è solo
vittima come fai così sco rimanere il
residuo carta stress intenso e castana
angeles e tv da colle alle ronde perche
si adoperi classi può andare bene il
proprio mascara battere lambretta non
penso che un sentiero
per gli occhi nelle labbra allora in
genere non va molto bene usare trucchi
per gli occhi nella bre viceversa perché
sono stati testato gli occhi o testati
per le labbra quelli potrebbero dare
qualche reazione allergica dello presto
per fare lasciato un trucco guarda alla
zona di incollare gli occhi aperti addio
cose da dire ma cosa ti piace un testo
bellissimo sito tantissimo questo per
fare line e rosanna sicura perfetto
cucchiaino quando un camion a torino
bravo anche state svegliate se 25 poi
alle 22
allora la sveglia alle sei e venticinque
però quando lo spegne si alzo dal letto
di 3 o 4 che ti alzi contato nove
disegni
scusate allora scrivete nei commenti
voi sa che ora risvegliato anche la rete
la sveglia è più la mia statura letto
appena suona la sveglia ci si alza dal
letto da presidente in più dall
[Musica]
intervista
allora qua con touring andati a
conoscere così funzione lo so le vostre
fa paura ma sapere che si poteva fare
anche al nato e nessuna differenza
se volete che cosa sia e le origini fini
come l'acqua o me piacciono mostra
colera in tv di cui avete le lenticchie
[Musica]
basta
oddio in bocconi a entrare lo smalto se
lo metti nell'acqua fredda tessuto più
in fretta
se i denti gialli si prende della carta
argentata dentifricio bicarbonato di
sodio per la bolla la media ed opinione
entra in contatto che diventiamo non
posso mica così nessuno si accorse della
verità allora gli interventi di gianni
che sembravano colorati per veramente
che è successo di mamma vado a non
sappiamo ma non c'è nemmeno una nemmeno
pa già fanno venire i complessi questi
video perché ti fanno piacere
oddio ma allora io a sono già facendo
con touring alla pancia o no surrender
eboli vinti e poi mangiarsi la panna dal
caso noemi
boh
allora realtà seccati come
trucco potrebbero farvi male agli occhi
forme perché non sono dei trucchi
testati sugli occhi potrebbe farvi
qualche reazione allergica l'effetto è
bellissimo questo sindaco vale opera
usate qualcosa che è stato testato da
vedere negli occhi perché se non
potrebbe farvi male punti neri catalogo
provata come che anni fa chi se la
ricorda solo che la faccia il prossimo
anno almeno stand erano tutti i punti e
poi file spin off non si è asciugata
avviene solo questa signora un po
[Applauso]
e adesso siamo bellissimi senza puntini
disegnati credibili se questa è la crisi
blender e si rovina facilmente non
lavata spesso vediamo subito caso le
macchine enormi adesso non lo so vi di
dire che trovare ovviamente parlando
venere che funziona bisogna trovare
sempre paura capisco che la monica
nostra ma non è più solo qua crea
qualche altro greco liquido fatto lo
slime no a per le sopracciglia e l
purificazione vada mobile regionale le
stime ferree colora anche fermato da
pulire
domani dopo quando la sera con tutti
stranieri
cosa provo io non sono farina le ditte
seguito di non intendere che fare con
touring abbiamo provato bello questo
condiziona insieme a bene si può sarà
pure per i quadri di bob rosso per fare
gli alberi
è vero e proprio con la forma c'è una
passante che cos'è il consiglio il
correttore e di guardare una perfetta
senso la magia non vuol dire il trucco
quando è finito il fondotinta blick
aggiungi della crema da questo funziona
però lo rende un po meno coprente
programma bianca ma anche un po più
chiaro però abbiamo di da soli però è
rimasto nel tubicini è noto
[Applauso]
sempre per farlo sottile finito per
cambiare la forma bello bello
ci piace allora perché erano i
trucchetti per oggi avremmo continuato a
guardarli per tipo un'ora ma meglio però
troppo quando vi ha giocato di più ad
avere un assetto con color crayon che si
parla così con la sera mi costernazione
che si deve davvero così ma c'è un
trucchetto che il prezzo che funzioni
non è niente di per mac è strano e
faccio quello che ti devi disegnare
dominando in un ora e dove vai a
mangiarti la panne quello che voi
pertanto agli addominali investiti per
la prima volta qui diceva sei pronta per
l'estate ma certo quelli in estate e va
infatti il bagno poi sporchiamo lo zero
voi cosa ne pensate scrivete vinto nei
commenti di stile quale mi ha scioccato
di più qual è secondo voi è più utile o
inutile
nei commenti ricordatevi le date delle
firma copie e ora vi lasciamo un pò a 4
cartellino e su praticare per vedere i
nostri altri video i nostri f trucchetti
assurdi challenge video divertenti
cliccate su quello che preferite e buona
visione